if you think wah-wah is a store you
won't mind prison yeah chef like an
omelet chef every morning if you think
why was a store you're just correct you
just have traveled this great land
if prison food is like Wawa food well
then sign this guy up I'm gonna shoot
this guy in the head right what do you
wanna do off DJ loo yeah I'll do it
tell me I go wah wah every day and I get
to talk to the cause I get to write my
slam poet I swam homes but you know
somebody there's like a lab for all the
the wah food and there's a couple men
where that's you know what are the heads
of the company is like trying the new
hamburger yeah this is fantastic like
you know there's a massive process for
every product yeah oh absolutely I did I
do like a little test true drops like
yeah now that tastes like ranch
I did a commercial for Doritos yeah it
was that Super Bowl commercial thing
that everyone does every year do you
know but I remember when you did that
Matt McCarthy right yeah yeah Doritos
beer yeah spot that we won with we
didn't win with the whole thing anyway
so we got to go and they were giving us
a tour of like frito-lay Doritos like
employees and so and one guy was like
yeah we can make it to Rita that tastes
like anything I was like what do you
mean he's like fresh mown grass that's
pretty interesting then he goes we made
one that tastes like fear disappears
like a pheromone you release
we ate achieve the to manage of the tisk
fear and then he goes we made one the
taste like mother like the sensation of
being a child with your mother that fair
mom that your mom releases which is
breastfeeding they were like would that
be a popular flavor is breast milk these
have a bunch like ladies with others
like I think Oh mother is almost ready
for tasting so much I read my red book
and just sit here oh you just got out of
the milking station they do a combo
flavor that makes you feel like you're
afraid of your mother oh that's what it
is
yeah or they can just have my mom raised
you and you could just live in constant
fear that way you know a gen pop yeah my
mom used only prison terms which was
time for the yard that's a cold hose now
that's ranch yeah God gives me the
babies and I sort them out but she goes
well if he's a little bit of a stickler
there's a real headline Bill Cosby to
get first serving of jell-o in jail
Thursday we'll have access to TV and
emails so you what what's his life he
finally has something to email people
isn't it weird that you could rape just
so many people and then the day you get
to jail who's gonna set up a Wi-Fi why
does he have mail and email email and TV
that's a sustainable he has such minimal
time left anyway that he doesn't need
more than those things
I bet at 81 years old he's happy someone
else is controlling the TV he's at that
age raised like I don't know how to
yeah yeah I'm afraid of the Internet you
see cuz someone read me my internet mail
are the demons in the box either the
Bhupinder plantain if you remember what
Bill Hicks is really mad that Jay Leno
did it Joey Lawrence thing where he says
he kills himself and yeah he's yeah he
says you're off the artistic roll call
when you work for what he did though
yeah Bill Hicks the story says about Jay
Leno that's how much the world has
changed where there's literally nobody
not doing a Doritos commercial and that
was a big thing like he sold out who's
furious yeah without Jalen I would love
to do I'll do it for fear and mommy
I'll push whatever chip they
want so most of your listeners yeah
listen on Sirius radio yeah but you like
to do a lot of visuals
yeah number one note from our executive
producer is we need to stop watching
videos to which we say we sit at the
bonfire SXM or Christine is non-stop
during the show putting up these
companion pieces the we'll see what
we're talking here but a lot of people
isn't on demand or steal it and we're
fine with both and then they can sync up
with our Twitter and see all the
pictures like steal it we don't care do
they still feel that way about the dip
that's when they used to email days
email there's only mail you the DVDs
yeah I still have one what do you have
what's the late fee on that yeah so
remember when you used to go to the what
was the video store you would forget to
return it and they would charge you like
$75 and that's watching a bankrupt
because everyone the second they had
another option they like night in jail I
spend a night in jail for that well
that's in gen-pop for not genpakuko
frozen bologna sandwich the whole nine
for not returning videotapes and in this
particular video store wasn't
blockbuster was a mom-and-pop store we
have to go now is where you'd go to get
there were some saloon doors you could
blow in adult films
took him never returned him that guy
would didn't notice he would take people
to court and he really would I wouldn't
be paying attention at like 18 years old
for court documents coming to my house
and you'd find out he took you to court
and you you know you lost cuz you didn't
show up and you have a bench warrant for
not showing up in court that's crazy
when you get pulled over for like you
know whatever your tail lights out or
some nonsense that got runs your thing
they go oh you're like you have a
warrant for your arrest they take in so
you went to a night of jail jhummer what
movies something I think used to get
these videos they were weird it was like
home videos I would be like Mardi Gras
or like these weird festivals around the
country where they would like have
people's like girls gone wild but like
dirtier but bros no wow is more of like
the showing just gone very well yeah
girls go next yeah girls gone batshit
I've told the story I'm embarrassed how
many times have told the story J is that
when I was crazy like super Christian
and back when you knew me when you first
met me and this is what crashing is
about that guy trying to be in T you and
I walk from the cellar to the corner and
you just care I'll never forget it you
go let me see that club magazine the guy
gives you club club club which is just
where stills of porn not like here's
some butt holes and you flipped through
it for what I don't know yeah I am so
ashamed I've ever masturbated and this
guy's just like maybe I'll take some
mental pics for later dude I love that
Jay do it for you sometimes give you a
free DVD young Samantha Fox was a part
of club I guess he not girls need love
too I mean you want to judge the place
but let's just say that a young Samantha
Fox was involved the covers are hardcore
pornography this is like jugs you can't
say give me the jugs
this is why they keep them in plastic
bags usually do they have to open that
place didn't did they have
I knew wait ariana grande is not on a
club okay that's different Club ex yeah
by the way for the record before we let
you guys go
I'm gonna go still maureen mccormick is
probably getting the biz before you plum
but he plumbs right in there
is she older than maureen mccormick like
in real life
uh-huh and we're Cindy I'm an ALICE guy
I said you helped firm on that always
see it I told you man right now
I looked as a young boy I said the same
the butcher is a lucky guy she
takes care of the broth of the Brady
family and a would be a good crushing
post team for the night especially cuz
I'm all I'm all six Dan's blossom six
yeah yeah Jeff on a thin waist big old
booty no six your boss no no dance
coming in for blossoms she has big
Jewish chitti's that's his words I'm
more Johnny Bravo Johnny Bravo yeah
barrel chest I get it strong forearms
strong strong forearms crashing how much
did we like six just cuz she was named
sex though I was cool and the hats in
the hats
[Music]